[Music]
so these are two main approaches to
language there's prescriptivism and
descriptivism prescriptivism is a belief
that the best practices of English will
prevail and so you champion the best
practices of English and the idea of the
best practices of English they sort of
take a very broad look at the
established canon of literature and use
that these script abysm is another
approach to language and it's one the
dictionary views and that is that that
you are a chronicler of language you
record the language as it's used and not
as you want it to be used so editors are
prescriptivists for instance because
they're trying to establish a standard
way of writing or a standard tone or
standard voice for a publication
dictionaries are descriptivists because
the goal of a dictionary is to record as
much of the language as you can and even
though prescriptivists and writers and
editors champion the best practices of
English the best practices of English
aren't all the things that end up in
print so so as descriptivists we sort of
look at everything that makes it into
prints for good bad and ugly and and
enter those into the dictionary when
they meet the criteria i didn't identify
as a descriptivists before i got to
merriam-webster i was a prescriptivists
when you grow up sort of in our the way
that our American educational system
works you grow up inside of this set of
grammar rules and those grammar rules
are prescriptive so when I started my
job one of the first things that they
said is you have to be willing to let go
of any linguistic prejudices you have to
record the language so I moved from
being a prescriptivists into being a
descriptivists and I still have there's
still times when I'm prescriptive
there's still times when I see it word
and say oh I don't like it but but yeah
I didn't I wasn't in the descriptivists
before I started this job
I think there is value in defaulting to
a descriptivists view of language
because what a descriptivists view of
language assumes is that the person
you're speaking with has an equal
command of the language that you do and
that their English is just as good as
your English and particularly in a
business setting when you're dealing
with employees or your vendors or
customers from all over the place that
has to be the basis for any kind of
communication that that you're both on
equal footing so and I think when you do
that you also get a chance to learn more
about people in your organization so if
I have an employer that says y'all I can
ask you know oh did you grow up in the
south and and I get to find out more
about the people in my organization that
way whereas if you just say y'all is not
appropriate in a business setting that
immediately shuts someone out and it and
it puts a morale charge on their own
language that you don't necessarily want
it doesn't foster communication or or
respect even when you decide that word
like irregardless or the pronounciation
nucular are wrong you are excluding a
whole group of people who use those
words naturally and they might not print
irregardless and they might be very
careful when they say nuclear to make
sure they're saying nuclear but but
those words actually have irregardless
is a really long history it's over 200
years old and it's appeared in print all
over the english-speaking world and the
pronunciation nucular is actually though
we think that it's sort of we say it's
an uneducated pronunciation it's
actually used by some of the most highly
educated people in the public domain so
nuclear physicists will say nucular and
irregardless has been used in oral
arguments on the Supreme Court so so
when you when you say irregardless isn't
appropriate or it's illiterate or you
say nuclear isn't how you say that word
it's just a
way of of pushing out people's
experiences and pushing out sort of
uttering people's identity really
because these are these are parts of who
they are and you can say irregardless
isn't appropriate in formal writing
which is true and you can say most
people say nuclear which is also true
but to say irregardless is wrong nuclear
is wrong really brings morality into an
area where morality doesn't have any
place
[Music]